[Musique]
vous avez des doutes sur l'origine d'une
photo d'une image vous vous demandez
s'il est bien vrai authentique si elle
n'a pas été trafiqués modifié altérée et
bien sachez que le site force écrit peut
être un atout à votre portée pour
satisfaire la curiosité du détective en
vous et l'équipe des décrypteurs pierre
des journalistes en vérification de fait
aussi utilisent cet outil un outil qui
vous permet d'analyser de décortiquer
des éléments d'une image et de
déterminer c'est une manipulation a eu
lieu ou à tout le moins d'obtenir des
indices et qui vont dans ce sens là
voyons ensemble très concrètement comme
en france et qui fonctionne pour les
fins de l'exercice on peut prendre
l'image d'un ovni survolant une ville
qui est proposé par défaut en se rendant
sur le site de france écrit dans le menu
de droite en anglais il ya une
fonctionnalité qui s'appelle comme
détection ou la détection de clown ça ça
vous permet de voir si deux ou encore
plusieurs éléments dans la photo ont été
copiés et copier coller à plusieurs
reprises dans ce cas ci on peut voir que
des nuages dans le ciel ont été
reproduits plus d'une fois à l'identique
très étrange d'espoir on peut donc
présumer que l'image a été trafiquée
c'est un outil très utile si par exemple
une photo un peu suspecte montre une
grande foule et vous vous demandez si
elle est véridique et s'il n'a pas été
produite en générant des portions à
l'identique d'autres fonctionnalités
utiles sont l'analyse du bruit entre
guillemets et aussi du niveau d'erreur
c'est un langage un peu technique du
jargon mais ça permet de trouver en
quelque sorte ce qui cloche dans l'image
précisément ce qui détonne ce qui a pu
être ajoutés ou modifiés en utilisant un
logiciel d'édition de photos ici on voit
que l'ovni ressort très clairement cet
élément n'était probablement pas présent
à la photo originale testons maintenant
ce procédé avec une image récente
publiée dans le contexte de la guerre en
ukraine alors cette photo il s'agit
d'une garderie détruites par des tirs
juste avant l'invasion russe vous aurez
remarqué ici la présence d'une pelle
mécanique pour le ccri permet de
constater que cette belle a été en fait
ajouté à l'image on voit ici qu'elle
ressort en surbrillance des
vérificateurs de faits l'ont d'ailleurs
analysé et conclut que l'image a été
altérée finalement sachez aussi que
fonseka lui fournit les métadonnées des
photos analysé soit les coordonnées
géographiques de l'endroit où elle était
prise si ces données ont été conservés
dans le fichier de la photo bien sûr de
très précieux indices pour en comprendre
l'origine bref je vous parle ici
d'outils qui sont à votre disposition
pour débusquer les images trafiquées
altéré faites en bon usage et bien sûr
rester vigilant
[Musique]